COREY PERRY, VETERAN WITH PIERRC
STREAMING SWAYMAN.
>> ANDY: NO RONTO, WHO VISITS 5
DAYS  MORE
LIKE IT NICE PLAY HERE
WITH
NALTY
KILLING, YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR IF YOU
ARE THE TAMPA
THE PASS,
LINDHOLM CHECKS BOTH
BOXES AND THEN HAULA
WITH A
ANSWER COMES.
CLIFTONSPOKE TO BE.
FREDERIC TO SMITH
JUST
PUTTING A LITTLE
PRESSURE ON.
SMITH DODO
CERNAK BACK EFFICIENCY
OF MOVEMENT ALLOWS
HIM TO TRACK PERIOD.
HEDMAN STEAMS ALL THE
THEY NEEDED THIS OAL,
OPPORTUNITY, BOLTS.
>> ANDY: NICE
ROTATION HERE,
EXECUTDN'T COME
BACK ON THAT RUN
DOWN, AND WAS FORCED
BACK INTO TALK ABOUT MA
SOMETHING OUT AT PUCK
INITIALLY, MAYBE
GOING TO HIS BACK
END, BUT WHEN THAT
DOESN'T MATERIALIZE,
HE DOESN'T
THTHLAYER, FORWARD.
KUCHEROV, TO THE
POINT, AND A
HIP WALL
BY SMITH PASTRNAK TO
CREATE THE 2 ON
FREDERIC TURNED
AROUND.
A WELL EXECUTED PLAY. O
SIDESKATE.
HE KEEPS IT IN THE
ATTACKING ZONE, AND
PAUL PASTRNAK, HAT
TRICK.
THE BRUINS
AT THE PUCK.
O THE
NET.
FIND IT, LOCATED IT,
GET TO THTHPAUL
DOWN.
VASILEVSKIY IS ON THE
BENCH, 6TH GAME